el domingo 4 de septiembre de este año
más de 70.000 personas se manifestaron
en Praga a favor de Rusia habéis oído
bien esas 70.000 personas pedían que su
país República Checa se rinda ante Rusia
y deje de sancionarla para que vuelva al
gas natural barato pensadlo bien los
checos han estado invadidos por los
rusos durante décadas vamos que saben lo
que significa ser una colonia de Rusia
si esto es lo que está ocurriendo en
chequia imaginad en otros países
europeos que no han vivido una ocupación
Rusia en Francia también han tenido
protestas similares y en España donde
Ucrania queda bastante lejos algunas
voces parecen pedir algo parecido
atentos a lo que dice el ex
vicepresidente del gobierno Pablo
Iglesias los ciudadanos europeos van a
tener que seguir pagando una fractura
social demasiado alta para la propia
estabilidad de la Unión Europea y os
preguntaréis Pero por qué hay tanta
gente que se quiere rendir ante Rusia La
respuesta es simple Europa parece
dirigirse hacia todo un casmagedón
si recordáis hace unas semanas sacamos
un vídeo aquí en visualpolitik donde
hablábamos de la crisis del gas natural
Pues bien ni siquiera en nuestros peores
escenarios pensábamos que Putin cortaría
todo el gas que se envía Europa
sin embargo es amenaza parece estar ya
concretándose el 1 de septiembre Rusia
anunció que cortaba todo el gas que
pasaba por el gasoducto norestream y un
20% en un 10% nada
0% de garroso Sí todavía sigue llegando
algo de carruso a través de Ucrania de
Turquía pero hablamos de un suministro
mucho más reducido y lo cierto Es que
desde que diera comienzo la Guerra de
Ucrania Moscú ha estado reduciendo
progresivamente el suministro de gas
Europa como medida de presión
Putin está utilizando la energía como
arma al cortar el suministro y manipular
nuestros mercados energéticos el fallará
Europa prevalecerá Úrsula wonderley en
presidenta de la comisión europea dicho
de otra forma que la recesión en Europa
es casi Inevitable y el razonamiento de
gas también vamos a decirlo claro
estamos en una guerra energética con
Rusia en lugar de enviarnos a todos los
europeos a un gulag siberiano Putin ha
enviado un poquito de Siberia a nuestras
casas y no creáis que hablamos solo de
calefacción también Hablamos de
Electricidad todos estamos viendo como
la factura de la luz está disparando En
algunos momentos hablamos de pagar hasta
dos veces lo que pagábamos antes y como
os podéis imaginar muchos tienen pánico
a lo que podría ser el invierno más frío
y caro de nuestra vida un auténtico gas
magedón
y mientras todo esto ocurre Rusia parece
estar resistiendo el impacto de las
sanciones O al menos eso parece o mejor
dicho eso se empeñe a mostrar el kremlin
por ejemplo mientras Europa está
rompiéndose la cabeza para ver cómo
responde a la crisis del gas Putin acaba
de inaugurar una de las mayores norias
de Europa El Sol de Moscú y Putin sigue
asegurando que Rusia no ha perdido ni
perder a nada
[Música]
Así que la tentación de muchos es Y si
nos rendimos obviamente esta opción está
más que descartada como os podéis
imaginar si Europa se rinden de Putin no
habrían nada que impidiera que invadiera
otros países además serviría para que
china invadiera Taiwán o por lo menos se
sintiera más envalentonada para hacerlo
con lo cual solución descartada pero no
solo eso y si os dijera que el precio a
pagar No va a ser tan alto dicho de otra
forma tenemos un problema Sí pero no es
ni mucho menos el gas magedón que muchos
se imaginan no me creéis pues atentos a
esta gráfica
[Música]
lo que veis aquí son los futuros del gas
ttf holandés el índice de referencia del
precio del gas si os dais cuenta el pico
del precio del gas llegó el 26 de agosto
es decir cuatro días antes del corte
total del gas ruso tras el anuncio del
cielo del Norte los precios no solo no
han subido sino que siguen bajando por
supuesto el gas Sigue estando
extremadamente caro ahora cuesta 6 veces
más que hace un año ahora bien el hecho
de que la noticia de Putin no haya
disparado al precio del gas es muy
revelador todavía no estáis sorprendidos
Pues atentos porque aquí llega otro dato
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la Unión Europea quería tener sus
depósitos de gas natural al 80% para el
1 de noviembre Pues bien ese objetivo ya
se superó a comienzos de septiembre en
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
Europa ha llenado el 85,6% de sus
reservas de gas es decir sin apenas
garroso Europa ya tiene reservas para
llegar hasta navidad es más con las
medidas de ahorro energético esta
reservas podrían durar para más tiempo
sí es cierto este invierno veremos como
la Torre Eiffel y tantos otros
monumentos emblemáticos estarán apagados
por la noche y no va a ser un invierno
fácil e incluso algunos países pueden
tener que establecer algún tipo de
racionamiento o limitación pero
tranquilos porque todo apunta a que se
puede evitar el gas magedón
[Música]
la pregunta ahora es cómo de dónde está
sacando Europa todo ese gas natural que
sustituye al garruso Cómo se van a
resolver las subidas Nacho vidalianas
del precio de la electricidad y lo que
es más importante Por qué decimos que
Rusia está mucho peor de lo que parece
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes antes sabéis Cómo podéis
apoyar a visualpolitik de forma activa
pues entrando en nuestra comunidad de
patreon no solo estaréis contribuyendo a
que visualpolitik siga adelante siendo
un medio independiente sino que además
tendréis acceso merchandising como esta
camiseta que llevo puesta no está a la
venta y nunca lo estará la única forma
de conseguirlas formando parte de
nuestra comunidad pero no solo eso
también tenemos una newsletter semanal
las claves de la semana donde tratamos
temas que no nos da tiempo a cubrir en
forma de vídeos así que ya sabéis os
espero a todos en la comunidad de
visualpolitik en patreon y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
una de las mayores críticas del
capitalismo es que beneficia a los ricos
verdad pues hay ocasiones donde Es
verdad Esta es una de ellas ahora bien
sabéis Quiénes son los ricos de esta
historia Exacto la Unión Europea vamos a
decirlo claro Europa tiene dinero y como
Europa tiene dinero se ha marcado un tío
gilito y se ha hecho con todo el mercado
del gas a golpe de talonario lo vemos ya
en el anterior vídeo de esta serie El
Mercado del gas en el año 2022 parece un
bazar Turco cuánto te paga Pakistán por
este barco de gas no da igual yo te pago
más conclusión
como veis en la Gráfica el precio del
gas ha subido durante todo el verano Por
qué Pues porque los europeos estaban
dispuestos a pagar auténticas fortunas
para que todos esos barcos de gas
natural licuado desviaran su ruta hacia
costas europeas gracias a todo esto las
reservas de gas natural se han llenado
en tiempo récord A pesar de Rusia todo
esto da un balón de oxígeno que puede
durar hasta la Navidad pero no solo eso
la Gráfica son los precios spot es decir
los precios de los futuros de gas con
vencimiento inmediato ahora bien atentos
a esta otra gráfica
[Música]
aquí podéis ver los futuros del gas en
el largo plazo Por ejemplo si compramos
un futuro de gas holandés con fecha de
vencimiento 2026 nos cuesta casi lo
mismo que antes de la guerra que
significa todo esto pues esto significa
que los inversores de gas que manejan
mucha más información que el común de
los mortales esperan que el gas termine
bajando Y diréis por qué Pues porque
poco a poco están apareciendo nuevas
alternativas algas ruso por ejemplo
Noruega está explotando gas a niveles
récord pero sin duda alguna el nuevo
super proveedor de gas es Estados Unidos
os lo hemos contado ya en visualpolitik
en anteriores vídeos donde decimos que
el Tío Sam está exportando más gas
Europa que nunca pero ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando si sois veteranos
seguidores de visualpolitik ya sabéis
que casi todo este nuevo gas que llega a
Europa no lo hace por tuberías
[Música]
lo hace a través del gas natural licuado
o gnl y este gas tiene un problema muy
grande y cuál es el problema Pues que
para comprar gnl necesitas tener una
planta regasificadora en tu país dicho
de otra forma el gas sale del yacimiento
y se convierte en líquido gracias a esto
se puede transportar en barco pero una
vez llega el destino hace falta volver a
convertirlo en gas natural verdad Para
eso hacen falta las llamadas plantas
regasificadoras Pues bien hasta ahora
Europa tenía muy pocas plantas de este
tipo por ejemplo Alemania no tenía
ninguna Por qué Pues porque el gas venía
por gasoductos que es mucho más barato
casi todas las plantas clasificadoras
estaban en España pero España es una
isla energética apenas está conectada
con el resto del continente Así que la
pregunta es cómo es posible que ahora
Europa pueda comprar tantísimo gnl de la
noche a la mañana que ha pasado la
respuesta está de nuevo en el
capitalismo
como Europa es rica y puede poner el
dinero encima de la mesa Boom aparecen
soluciones milagrosas que antes eran
impensables algo parecido a lo que
ocurrió con la vacuna del covid y
creedme ahora mismo hay mucho pero que
mucho dinero encima de la mesa atentos
Alemania destina 3000 millones de euros
para terminales de gnl flotantes os
presento un nuevo prodigio de la
tecnología las terminales de gas natural
flotantes también conocidas como fsrus
esto es mucho más rápido y sobre todo
muchísimo más barato una fsru cuesta
entre 400 y 500 millones de dólares y se
tarda en construir unos 3 años pero
Incluso se puede hacer más rápido y más
barato como convirtiendo barcos
metaneros que ya existen en terminales
flotantes Y sí esto se puede hacer y de
hecho es un proceso rapidísimo puede
llevar unos 18 meses y cuesta entre 100
y 150 millones de dólares pero no solo
eso como son terminales flotantes se
puede mover de un sitio a otro en
cuestión de meses para que os hagáis una
idea ahora mismo hay 38 terminales
flotantes en el mundo y 558 barcos
metaneros Es decir barcos que llevan gas
natural licuado en el año 2021 Europa
solo tenía cuatro terminales flotantes
pero eso está cambiando a toda velocidad
si recordáis el gas natural se mide en
bcms es decir miles de millones de
metros cúbicos de gas pues bien en el
momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
Países Bajos ya tiene dos terminales
flotantes que pueden procesar 14 bcms
nuevas República Checa que no tiene
salida al mar ya contratado tres bcms de
una de estas terminales pero el caso de
Alemania es aún más impresionante
Alemania y asegurado seis plantas
flotantes tres de ellas por cierto van a
estar listas para funcionar para estas
Navidades y ahora vamos a hacer un
pequeño recuento el año pasado Alemania
compró a Rusia entre 45 y 50 bcms de gas
natural Pues bien solo con la capacidad
regasificadora que ya han contratado
Alemania podrá importar entre 40 y 45
bcms de gas natural
[Música]
dicho de otra forma que para el invierno
próximo Alemania ya podrá prescindir de
casi todo el garroso al menos en lo que
respecta la infraestructura de recepción
Así que ahora la carrera pasa por lograr
proveedores pero como os hemos dicho la
buena noticia para Europa es que el
viejo continente tiene dinero
evidentemente el creciente coste de
suministro afectará la economía pero no
tanto como gasmagedón total Pero esto no
es la única gran noticia en el momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo España y
Alemania están presionando a Francia
para que desbloquee la construcción del
gasoducto que conectaría la Península
ibérica con el resto de Europa
En otras palabras que sí hay alternativa
algas ruso pero ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos Sí vale Jaque mate a
Rusia y lo que tú quieras Fonseca pero Y
quién paga mi factura de la luz yo no
puedo llegar a fin de mes existe
solución para esto Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
evitar el gas magedón
Europa rica y tiene dinero para pagar el
gas ahora bien No todos los europeos son
tan ricos como para pagar los precios
Nacho vidalianos de la factura de la
electricidad y aquí es donde viene una
pregunta interesante República Checa es
uno de los países donde más está
subiendo el precio de la Luz Sin embargo
los checos tienen centrales nucleares
que suponen el 18% de sumix no se
suponía que la energía nuclear era
barata cómo es posible que eso no
abarate la factura de la luz de los
checos y aquí es donde entra nuestro
amigo el sistema marginal de precios es
decir el precio de la electricidad lo
fija la Fuente más cara veréis todos los
países tienen una empresa normalmente
Estatal que gestionan la red eléctrica
nacional estos entes son los que compran
la energía a las centrales nucleares los
puertos solares las plantas de gas quien
sea y se las venden a las empresas
eléctricas por ejemplo nature o
iberdrola en España todos los días esta
empresa hace una subasta para cubrir
toda la demanda de Electricidad de ese
día por ejemplo vamos a imaginar que
España espera consumir hoy 30.000
megavatios de energía Pues bien abre la
subasta y entran las fuentes más como la
nuclear pensad que las plantas nucleares
funcionan continuamente Así que
independientemente del precio van a
suministrar conclusión su precio siempre
cero euros Por qué Pues porque van a
vender sí o sí después entran las
energías verdes que son más caras luego
el carbón las hidroeléctricas etcétera y
finalmente llegamos al gas
[Música]
y claro como el gas está disparado de
precio las centrales de gas no pueden
vender por debajo de una cantidad vamos
a decir 190 euros por megavatio hora
Pues bien el precio del megavatio para
ese día sería de 190 euros Y eso es lo
que se paga a todos los demás
proveedores Este es el sistema marginal
de precios y hasta ahora había
funcionado muy bien problema pues que no
estaba pensado para condiciones de
guerra qué está pasando ahora pues que
los productores clásicos de energía
nuclear verde etcétera están haciendo
unos beneficios extraordinarios y
quiénes son los grandes perjudicados
Exacto los consumidores y las empresas
energéticas que compran todo a esa
energía pensando bien cuando naturgy
compra la red eléctrica española está
pagando precios prohibitivos pero en
muchos casos los consumidores pagan
tarifas planas por la electricidad dicho
de otra forma No solo hay consumidores
que no llegan a fin de mes sino que
también hay muchas empresas eléctricas
de toda Europa que están al borde de la
bancarrota Y eso explica noticias como
esta la compañía energética uniper pide
un rescate y diréis cómo se puede
solucionar todo esto
Pues el debate está sobre la mesa en
este mismo momento algunos países
quieren intervenir el sistema de precios
de esta forma en lugar de fijar precios
por subasta los fijaría el estado el
problema Pues que esto daría el traste
con el mercado energético y quebrantaría
la seguridad jurídica a largo plazo
todos son problemas que otra solución se
puede aplicar pues muy fácil que paguen
más Quienes más tienen y quiénes son
esos ahora mismo Exacto los productores
de energía hablamos de poner un impuesto
a los beneficios extraordinarios que
están ganando los dueños de plantas
nucleares molinillos eólicos huertos
solares etcétera esos impuestos
servirían para pagar dos cosas posibles
rescates a las eléctricas y sobre todo
subsidios a los consumidores que ahora
mismo están ahogados por las facturas de
la luz y por otro lado otros países como
Alemania están tomando otro tipo de
soluciones drásticas para evitar mayores
distorsiones soluciones como esta
Alemania incauta la refinería rusas de
rosnev que están en su territorio
conclusión que la situación está
cambiando día a día Pero que Existen
varios recursos para evitar el
casmagedón sí es cierto este invierno
vamos a ver ciudades medio apagadas la
sagrada familia de Barcelona no encender
las luces Por la noche y todos vamos a
pagar facturas abultadas pero habrágas
en invierno y hay dinero para dar ayudas
que eviten los problemas sociales y
ahora un dato curioso recordáis esa
Noria que acaba de inaugurar Vladimir
Putin en Moscú pues ya está cerrada por
problemas técnicos y esto es una figura
muy simbólica de lo que realmente está
ocurriendo en Rusia
[Música]
como ya hemos cubierto nuestro canal
hermano visual economic Por cierto si no
lo conocéis no sé que estáis haciendo ir
verlo y suscribiros la fortaleza del
rublo ruso es el único buen indicador
que tienen pero recordad dos cosas uno
el gas y el petróleo que Rusia vendía
Europa suponía el 45% de todas sus
exportaciones es decir que en este
momento Rusia tiene un agujero en sus
cuentas públicas tan Nacho vidaliano
como las facturas de luz que pagaremos
los europeos 2 El coste de la guerra en
este momento el kremlin está
planteándose hacer una alistamiento
masivo es decir obligar a todos los
jóvenes rusos a ir a la guerra esto no
solo tendría un coste político sino
también económico porque tienes que
entrenar armar y alimentar a millones de
soldados y mientras tanto Putin ya se ha
reunido con sin pin esperando un apoyo
de China que no está llegando china
sigue de perfil en la Guerra de Ucrania
de hecho el kremlin está tan desesperado
por conseguir municiones y armamento del
extranjero que podría estar comprando a
Corea del Norte y ya sabéis la
tecnología militar norcoreana es
punterísima dijo nadie nunca así que por
el momento el apoyo de Beijing a Moscú
se está quedando en buenas palabras y la
India ya empieza a presionar a Rusia
para que termine la guerra de una vez
por todas En otras palabras que Putin
está cada vez más en apuros ha perdido
todas sus gafas para negociar en Europa
ha perdido su principal fuente de
ingresos y está perdiendo la Guerra de
Ucrania Pero de todo eso hablaremos con
más detalle en próximos vídeos porque
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que la economía rusa va a
colapsar os parece que estas medidas
serán suficientes para que Europa evite
el gas magedón este invierno o tal vez
veremos nuevas subidas del precio del
gas podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis Que aquí en visualpolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos Todas las semanas
así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones recordad que
también podéis apoyarnos activamente
formando parte de nuestra comunidad de
patreon si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]